now for our daily cancellation it's time
for another of the fabled
reverse cancellations this is uh when i
am in the midst of being canceled myself
yet i managed to break free turn the
tables and cancel the cancellers it's
always very exciting
so today i'm canceling those who are
trying to cancel me for my take on the
cleveland indians who announced that
they'll be changing their name because
the name
indians is offensive somehow to indians
incidentally the cleveland browns
lost last night to the baltimore ravens
on a 55-year-old
yard field goal in the final seconds of
the game after lamar jackson the
baltimore ravens quarterback had run
back onto the field after missing half
of the fourth quarter with cramps that
some say
was probably code for he had to use the
bathroom anyway my point is that
i like to think the sports gods were
punishing the city of cleveland for its
cowardice
um not that the city of cleveland really
needs to be punished when it comes to
sports anymore than it already has been
over the last several decades
in any case the indians will not be the
indians anymore
this news has been celebrated by those
on the left to assure us that the
native american community never feels
more seen and understood and respected
than when all mention of the native
american community is removed from
popular culture
indeed tmz reports today that native
american leaders expect that the suicide
rate
in that community is going to go down
because the cleveland baseball team has
chosen a different mascot
i'm not making that up that is really
what is being claimed that it's going to
lower the suicide rate i briefly
mentioned this story about the cleveland
baseball team on the show yesterday i
also mentioned it briefly on twitter
in both forums i argued as i have in the
past that
having a team name and a mascot based
around native americans
is no more or less offensive than having
one based on any other
group namely the irish the boston
celtics for example are called the balsa
boston celtics and their mascot is a
leprechaun
the fighting irish of notre dame also
have a leprechaun mascot only theirs is
a bit more
ornery this is the point that i posted
on twitter
i said uh quote quoting myself i have
never heard anyone ever complain about
the boston celtics and their
stereotypical mascot if cleveland indian
is offensive then so is this
but this isn't offensive to anyone with
a brain and a shred of
emotional maturity and neither is
cleveland indian
now i must admit i do deserve to be
canceled for this tweet
only because of the typo on then i
spelled it t-h-a-n instead of t-h-e-n
normally i have a policy of deleting all
typo tweets but i couldn't delete this
one because
leftists were mad at it for another
reason so i had to choose between
preserving my dignity and deleting it
because of the typo
or keeping the tweet up in service of
triggering the libs
as george washington once said when
given a choice between triggering the
libs
or not triggering them always trigger
them but much of the outrage
derision mockery etc directed at me is
not over the typo as it should be
but over the point that i'm making a
great many media people especially
sports media
have responded saying just to summarize
here basically they say
oh you idiot that's that's not the same
besides leprechauns are fictional
characters didn't you know that
what do you think the boston celtics is
offensive to leprechauns got him
yes leprechauns are fictional characters
okay then so you're saying you're saying
that's okay
so what you're telling me is that it's
okay to make a team name out of an
ethnic group
as long as the mascot is a make-believe
creature
associated with the traditions and
mythologies of that group
that's what you want to go with okay
well then here's my proposal
let's keep them the cleveland indians
and make their mascot a character from
native american folklore
the lakota for example believed in
forest spirits
who were like magical dwarves living in
the trees
uh ken otilia they called them probably
mispronounced it
is that better uh make them the indians
but with the magical dwarf as the mascot
sort of like a leprechaun
has that sound would that be okay oh no
no that wouldn't be
in fact that would be even worse
wouldn't it you'd say it's still a
problem because the name is still
indians
and now we've appropriated their
cultural mythology
and turned it into a mascot made a joke
of it
i've also been told that the fighting
irish and the celtics are not offensive
because those team names
are based on the predominant ethnicity
of their fan base
at least historically right a lot of
irish people in boston
okay so that's the rule now a basketball
team can make a group
race or ethnicity into a mascot as long
as it's a race or ethnicity common in
their fan base
something tells me this logic would get
a sports organization into a lot of
trouble if they tried to apply it to
virtually
anyone but the irish the other excuse
i've heard is that it's different
because native americans are
historically persecuted group
unlike the irish who famously have had
an enormously easy ride all through
history right
no of course not the irish have been
persecuted too in this country and their
own
so that excuse doesn't wash either see
when you sift through all of the
arguments for why it's offensive to make
indians into a team name
or a mascot but not the irish
you begin to quickly realize that all
the arguments are utter hogwash
as the kids would say whatever tortured
logic
makes indians or braves offensive must
also apply to drunken leprechaun mascots
to represent teams with irish and celtic
in their name
and those on the left here's the thing
they could quite easily make their point
achieve their desired end if they simply
said yeah you're right
that's offensive too let's get rid of
that also
but they won't say that they can't say
that
because that would be to admit that
non-white groups
shouldn't get any special consideration
nor do they corner the market on
persecution
nor should we have more respect for them
than we do any other
group it would be to it would be in
other words to treat
all groups equally which is the last
thing that anybody on the left
wants to do but they won't admit that so
they're stuck trying to find differences
where none exist
and ignore them where they do for that
reason
they are cancelled not me i'm only
partially cancelled for the typo thing
but i'm right about the mascot thing and
let's focus on what i'm right about
today and always well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content